bella tutti ragazzi della bella a tutti
i ragazzi niente volevo fare un'entrata
bella ma sta minkia pervenute questo è
un video sono fa vj e ci siamo su enzo
fight of here
dove siete arrapati tutti questa
pronuncia praticamente si chiama insert
hytok perchè sono dimenticati di dare il
titolo al gioco ragazzi insert taito
dire ma in giro ad esplorare va bene zio
altro che bella videocamera che ciò
potesse cagata andiamo avanti questo è
un esperimento si fosse serio jump devo
saltare non ti preoccupare non ti rompe
rai ha alcun osso questa è la logica del
gioco va bene non possono anche guardare
in basso che bellissima è una cosa muri
fatti di carta ragazzi hai urlato
qualcosa del tipo come cazzo fa sapere
perché è qualcosa di ritardato e si ti
sto dando del ritardato ma che
sperimento studia le tue reazioni ed è
per questo che abbiamo bisogno della tua
voce procediamo con qualcosa con te sei
tu una ragazza o sei un ragazzo
ovviamente io sono una ragazza quindi
vado nel caso della ragazza
mi dispiace ma devi essere un ragazzo
per giocare questo videogame lo sai
questo gioco e sessista
ma la madonna non me ne frega sono una
ragazza voglio giocare a questo [ __ ]
gioco va bene allora entriamo in questo
bocchino quando dicono eh no no va bene
che ascoltavo portatemi se va bene sono
un uomo perfetto che hai a posto
magari fosse una ragazza e stai mentendo
in questo momento mentire sbagliato non
sai che non sto mentendo credo è la
nostra mente allora quindi vai a cagare
fammi andare avanti questa stanza e
spaventosa non è così i ragazzi però
questa musica del cazzo non più di tanto
mi bene la musica che c'è in sottofondo
in questo momento non si intonaco il
gioco come cazzo fa sapere che ho fatto
suo ragionamento ma mista che mi sta
ascoltando sto gioco da correggere o più
avanti prima che amiamo stanza va bene
lo swan exchanges mirata mi fa un po
cagare prova bene vi assiste cioè globe
shawky e ciao bella la stanza delle
droghe che bel gioco che sto giocando ok
adesso devi uscire prima che il tuo
cervello abbia un attacco non la stai
tranquillo ci hanno già avuto usciamo
grazie ragazzi a che cosa straniti
assunto grano
devo leggere tutta sta cagata ma
[ __ ] bene adesso comincia il vero
esperimento ci vediamo dopo va bene ok
ragazzino scegliere tra queste tre porte
c'è scritto platform game collo game
psicologica al game allora io direi di
fare horror game dai [ __ ] primo
horror ma che bello
cosa devo prenderla sento dei rumori
rigano terminate ma è un vero gioco
horror una presa per il culo fatemi
capire perché adesso sto andando le
gabelle giorni scorsi buonuomo amy mi fa
vedere la sua bella testa non è un figo
ragazzi un figo trova un incrocio tra un
personaggio di skyrim è un horror a caso
salve lei è più bello del tizio di prima
giusto perché non ha la faccia una solta
una delle porte è quella corretta quale
forte questa quinta per la way place e
sopratutto cantieri ma ho azzeccato la
porta giusto quella sbagliata non sono
capitoli sono il matrix o mio dio
non ti sembra di essere osservato come
non voglio fare il grande fratello in
una stanza sola usciamo grazie ai
docenti pillola rossa o pillola blu
ragazzi quale delle due mi fa entrare
nella tana del bianconiglio non mi
ricordo quale delle due ragazzi aveva
faccio con la bonus che remo il suo ex
come fa a sapere quello che dico porca
[ __ ] mi mi dà fastidio sapere che un
gioco sa quello che dico è orribile
psicologica al crescente utilizzo due
film non me li ridò lo swing stomp lei
che cosa faresti se vincessi un milione
di dollari istantaneamente tutto per me
la mia famiglia oppure donarli a in
carità facciamo donazioni vediamo cos'è
seba microso è il mio migliore amico
morisco dai facciamo mi sacrifico per
lui no lo lascio crepare ovviamente non
è vero lui che sto scherzando
[Musica]
che belle ragazze la grafica visto gioco
per carità di dio
le ombre come sono fatte bene
meraviglioso di experience ma non può
essere finito così sono il personale
autorizzato che cazzo me ne mettono a
fare ste porte si stanno già che io ci
entrò qual è il problema ragazzi sardi
di merda fatemi entrare ovunque mai mai
mai mai mai mai mai della gente ce l'ha
mai detto nessuno che sei un figo ma sì
forse era meglio se c'era solo la testa
ciao fra testa a posto metti a ripartire
cani senza faccia andiamo avanti ragazzi
ancora devo capire il senso ci sono due
scenderne ed io che fastidio ragazzi
scusate vince un letto che vola possiamo
finire in questo caso di rumore grazie a
dio mi sta esplodendo il cervello rice
ha detto che io experiment perfetti c'è
una macchina da domandare posso
prenderla distanza l'ho presa dista e la
madonna a supplicare è perfetto di end
ma come di and tanto si vede attraverso
il muro la scritta ma cos'è e youtube
quella che cazzo spiegatemi sé ma che
cazzo ci fa youtube ma io una fine così
ragazzi non la posso accettare come
faccio fatemi conti io voglio continuare
a giocare mi impongo e oratio ragazzi a
vedere se scegliamo platform game invece
di porno gay salta e divertiti in questo
livello platform e non cadere va bene ci
provo
ripeto che tutto molto allegro il suo
gioco perché ti tagli diretto proprio
tutto bene fantastico che cazzo hai
mangiato un televisore che bel vento sei
molto sexy fratello
a sto passando sul dentro la mano geneve
ragazzi in gioco della nota ma arrivati
alla porta perfetto perche nuovo per la
privacy scegliamo l'uscita che cosa
succedeva di pratiche clicca qui quando
sei pronto va bene cosa goodbye cioè mi
fanno uscire quel questa è veramente un
uscita
qualcosa mi dice in questa anche
riprendendo ciao mamma sono morto quindi
ragazzi concludo quell'episodio spero
che vi sia piaciuto il video andato
proprio a un'esperienza che
la mia vita vorrei rifare miliardi di
volte non mi piace per la videocamera
che alla fine non si è rotta però le mie
palle sì quindi ragazzi servito è
piaciuto da subito lasciato quanto mi
piace anche la pagina di facebook e come
nei video trascrizione sapersi discreto
ci vediamo al prossimo video belle
ragazze